we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
bunch of these questions about the
connection the possible connection
between coronavirus and the election in
november take a listen
hello David name is Gerard longtime
follower question for you
if the coronavirus should keep going on
until November election time could
declare the election postponed canceled
and essentially go on as president
without an actual election not really so
here's the thing that first of all Trump
couldn't postpone the the election by
himself you would need congressional
support to do it
even with congressional support it would
be difficult to do Trump could say it
but that would not make it so because
Congress sets the time place and manner
of federal elections but the thing is
the following Congress would need to
rewrite three u.s. codes subsection
seven which has the time line for
electors which are chosen by States to
vote in the Electoral College remember
when we vote in November each state is
saying we want our electors to vote in
this way at the nominating convention
that is set for December 14th
so if lawmakers managed to delay the
election they really couldn't delay it
beyond you know a few days before
December 14th without having to rewrite
the Constitution itself which says the
president can hold office a term of four
years the election is happening at this
place so on and so forth now here's the
other thing that a lot of people are
worried about which is imagine that
Trump succeeds in doing it
does he just remain president and the
answer is no because this has been
researched the twentieth amendment
terminates each presidential term at
noon on January 20 so even if at the
federal level at the state's level
things were delayed Trump as president
would be terminated on January 20th
regardless now of course it would all be
a legal fight it would be unprecedented
territory but the idea that Trump could
do this to just stay in power for some
period of time seems extraordinarily
unlikely and not something that I would
I would put too much time into worrying
about the real question now is what's
going to happen with the primary
Louisiana and Georgia already deciding
to delay primaries there's now a fight
about whether the primaries happening in
March should even be delayed that is a
much more present present thing we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will actually talk about Georgia and
Louisiana postponing their primaries we
will talk about Trump saying that he's
going to waive federal student loan
interest due to coronavirus and we will
also talk about Trump considering a full
pardon for X advisor Michael Flynn we
knew it would happen all of those
stories and more on the bonus show get
access instantly by becoming a member at
join pakman.com I've got something
really cool today the first 500 people
who see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video